[Music]
hey everybody Welcome to Planet coaster
college today I'll be talking about the
fourth dimension coaster and showing you
how to build one though you might also
know it as the X Dimension or the test
pilot in game now just a fair warning
before we actually get into this this is
probably the single most difficult
roller coaster to build since its
distinguishing feature is the fact that
it has rotating seats on the side of the
track so you you don't only have to pay
attention to making the layout right but
also to get the rotation of the seat
right so this is a pretty difficult
thing which is made Harder by the fact
that there are only three of these in
real life which are all very similar uh
which I will be basing the coaster that
I'm building in this episode on um
though with some slight variations to
get a general idea of what this coaster
is like but much of my focus is really
going to be on how to get those
rotational seats done right because
they're super annoying and it's it's
confusing sometimes s anyway uh let's
get into it and start building one of
these all right now to start off as per
usual we want to take the station and
raise it up quite a bit especially on
these kinds of Coes they do have pretty
high up stations uh which I guess could
definitely work since these Coes are
very tall and Compact and uh doing this
at least saves us a little bit on break
run and LIF Hill space uh so I usually
just go ahead and raise these quite a
bit somewhere from 5 to seven cars on
one train should be more or less good at
least that's what they realistically
have uh so going with about five cars
over here is pretty good I think I would
go for the average of six but this
should do as well and before I get into
the lift Hill I Just Want to curve
around the coaster which is what they
what all of the real life versions do to
stay very compact so I want to do that
over here as well and just go down while
we're in the
curve something like that should be good
and what I'll also do is actually I
won't have the LIF hle completely
parallel with the station but actually
have it curv toward the station a little
bit which is something that they do do
in real life as well and I guess it does
save a little bit on space so that's
quite good and I want to grab the entire
first curve and smooth that out
especially for simple first elements
like this just grabbing the entire thing
at once and hitting the smooth button a
few times should more or less make them
smooth enough so now we're going to get
into a very important part which is the
lift Hill and this is important because
it's the first part where it actually
rotates the seats uh sometimes it does
mess with the seats I think on the part
before the LIF Hill but that's just a
bit of an optional thing that I guess
you can mess around with but here it's
the first part where we really want to
work on the seats now basically the way
that these things work let me just pause
the game while it's in the station for a
second the way that these things work is
you can see the seats like this and once
we start messing with the seed angle
over here when when it's zero it's just
like this uh but when we turn it up it's
going to rotate forwards and when we
turn it down it's going to rotate
backwards and so you'll see if I for
instance turn this uh rotation here to
minus 360 it's going to make a back flip
toward that track piece now obviously I
don't want to do that because we're just
on the lift Hill and what instead I want
to do is actually want to move one of
these things forwards and um have them
at about 6
like that so that they're going to be
lying flat on their back and that's
basically what we'll be doing during the
LIF Hill so as you can see when it gets
there it's going to go to about 60° you
actually uh turn the trick piece before
that down to
zero uh because this actually uh
illustrates another thing basically the
way that this works in game is you don't
have to set the rotation for each
individual track piece uh but all you
have to do is set a couple of track
track pieces with rotation and then the
game is automatically going to
transition from those different seat
positions uh between the different track
uh pieces basically I know that sounds
very complicated but if we take away
this rotation so it's going to go from
zero at the beginning to 60 over here uh
we can see that during this curve the
seats are going to position themselves
into 60° starting from zero at the
beginning and slowly transitioning to 60
at the end here now this this is very
important because you don't want to turn
off seat rotation for every single track
piece and just set it to whatever value
you want to on every track piece because
that's going to end up making the
rotation very UNS smooth you just want
to set a few important points where you
know how you want to position the seats
and then the game is automatically going
to transition between those very
important and that's basically the way
you want to make these if you want to
make sure that your seat rotation is
going to be smooth now if I change the
seat rotation over here and actually
turn it on and turn it to zero the next
time that we can see the cars pass by
which is going to happen right now
they're going to stay at zero until they
hit the track piece over here which is
when they're going to start to flip over
to 60° for the lift
til now with that little bit of theory
out of the way I want to start finishing
the litil itself which is interestingly
quite tall for these coasters they go
anywhere from round about 60 to 70 uh de
tall which puts them in hyper coaster
range it's ridiculous uh but that's
basically how large these things are so
I'm going to make mine 60 and a little
bit here CU I don't want to go too big
and that is basically going to be the
LIF Hill there's not too much about that
just want to make sure that the lift
Hill is about 30° and I definitely do
want to make the chain speed a bit
faster I don't have any values on the
exact chain speed but four is definitely
way too slow especially four a CO to
that size so I'll just turn it up a
little bit and then we'll go into the
first drop now as we transition into the
first drop we want to make sure that we
keep the catwalk and the chain around
for just a little bit there and then go
into the regular treack but we're not
going to go into the first drop straight
away we're actually going to have a
small pre-drop section right here where
we go up again and what we also want to
do for this pre drop is on one of these
track pieces we want to make sure that
we turn on the seat rotation otherwise
these seats might start rotating on the
lift Hill and that's something we don't
want so we're going to turn it on right
here and then we're going to get into
the actual drop of the coaster now what
I usually do because this makes my life
for me at least a little bit easier is
um I turn off the seat rotation and just
completely forget about it while I'm
shaping the track itself and then once
I'm done making the track I change the
seat rotation on certain places to make
sure that the seats are rotating
correctly now I guess this is just a bit
of a personal preference I guess you can
also uh adjust the seat rotation while
you're building the track pieces uh but
personally I just prefer not doing it
that way so I'm just going to do it
pretty much the simple way and make the
track first now what's quite interesting
about this hold up let me actually
smooth out this entire first little
section I think I can actually make that
a little bit more steep on some sections
as well yeah that can definitely be
improved I can just make one little
track piece out of this I
think there we go looks a bit better now
what's interesting about the first drops
is that these coasters have ftic core
first drops and so to transition into
that what I usually do is build three TR
piece three track pieces out of it and
um for the last one turn on the angle
snap so that we know we can go exactly
vertical and pretty much leave it at
that shaping isn't perfect but the
smoothing tool should take care of that
for a little bit and then once we come
very close to the ground we can have a
long winding curve over here
to make sure that we are going to come
to the ground with not too many forces
yeah that still looks a little bit
forceful so I make that a little bit
smaller especially because the speed is
so high when we're close to the ground
we want to make sure that this is a very
long smooth winding
drop I'll take that and I think it's
time to go into the first element of the
East coastes funnily enough even though
there are three coasters in the world
with this coaster type there are only
about three extra elements that these
Coes have there's the Raven turn which
is a sort of turnaround element which
looks like half a looping there's the
zero g which is just zero g roll a roll
as it goes over a hill and there's the
lie to fly Elements which is when it
goes from as from a piece of track which
is upward like this to a hanging piece
of track and those are really the only
three basic elements that these Coes
have aside from turns and LIF Hills
things like that uh and so the most sort
of Signature One and one that I'll be
starting with here is the Raven turn
it's very easy it's just a half Loop and
that is just about it and um the way you
can make it is basically kind of like
this shape up a uh half loop as you're
going up here and uh of course we do
want to make sure that the upper part of
the curve is a little bit more tight
than the bottom and smoothing it out
will also definitely make the curving of
that a little bit better especially
around the bottom here it's going up a
little bit too quickly for my taste so
I'll redo that and make it a little bit
larger around here make sure that we
kind of have the sort of loop shape to
it where it very like long winded sort
of goes into the looping and it only
comes into a more compact curve as it
reaches the top of the
loop so let's say something like that
should more or less look good now what's
going to be interesting about this and
this will look fine after a bit of
smoothing is that after the half Loop it
doesn't do anything it's just going to
stay inverted and that is pretty much
the element so on the other side of the
half Loop actually make this a little
bit smaller uh all we have to do is just
go down again and we're going to be fine
and that is really all there is to it
when it comes to this element it's very
simple to make and it's also very
strange
element and yeah all we do at this point
is basically just go down I think I can
make that a little bit
lower there we go that should just about
do now interestingly and I haven't
really been able to put my finger on
this the shaping of these Raven turns
kind of depends uh depending on the coer
that you're looking at I've noticed that
X2 has a very different shaping to the
turn than dinoconda has for example and
they're both Coes of the same type but
generally all you really want to make
sure with these elements is that you
have this half Loop element where it
goes inverted and after that goes down
again on the other
side I think that looks good enough now
for the first other elements that we
want to get into here I want to try and
make a zero g for this coaster and there
isn't really too much to zero g roll
it's just a hill with a roll in the
middle of it and uh not all of these
coasters have them but I think they're
very interesting elements add to these
kinds of coasters and you'll see that
once I get into the rotation uh into the
rotating seats uh that there's going to
be some interesting stuff happening
there so to make the zero g roll here I
just want to go down for a bit and then
have a section where we have the top of
the hill and this is where it's going to
start rotating so I want to rotate this
section 90° then get into a section
where it's going to go straight rotate
it 90° again do want to make that middle
section A little bit smaller and once we
go down we're going to go back again and
upside down and that is basically more
or less what we're looking for I know it
looks very UNS smooth at this point and
you also you always have to kind of
watch out with smoothing these elements
out because uh if you select the entire
ire thing at once it may very well just
ruin your banking so if I grab this it's
going to do weird things so I don't want
to do that but I definitely do want to
smooth out the hill once we get there
now once that's all done I think it's
time to get into the rotation of the
seats because that's pretty much what
we're all here for now the way that I
usually do this is for the first drop uh
or what they would do in real life is
you want to have the seats facing
downward over the drop so they're going
to kind of roll over toward the ground
as you go over this section of the drop
uh so what I want to do here is I want
to go to this track section and I want
to set the rotation over here uh to
minus
180° I also want to make sure that the
track section that I have here is
actually set to 60 so we're only going
to start rotating here that's good that
is all set at this point and what I also
want to do is I want to rotate so that
people are going to look toward the
middle of the giant raven turn over here
so the entire Raven turn you're sort of
pressed against your back against the
track and um that's how that's going to
work let's look at the rotation of the
first drop here it's quite good uh
though I do think yeah I could actually
set that a little bit earlier I'm going
to set it for just this track piece over
here that's good and then for the track
piece that's going to go up here I'm
going to set it to minus 270 and
hopefully that should make it so that
you're going to look toward the middle
of the Raven turn here and be on your
back against the track the entire time
and then once we get to the top section
and I'm just going to select a small
section here um I want to set it to
about minus 225 at least that's what
I've sort of tested myself and that
seems to keep the uh seats more or less
horizontal as we go into the top section
so we're not going to go completely
upside down but then after that I want
to go to track section here and go
completely in the other direction and
set it to 210 now this is this is sort
of an interesting little side note you
don't have to rotate the seats in the
middle of the section as it goes down
here um but this is something that I
believe Dino cond does which is one of
the versions of this coaster type and I
think it's a very interesting thing but
anyway let's quickly look at the seats
as it's passing by here it's going to
start rotating people on their backs
once they're here and um you can
actually see as we're going to be in the
looping here you're going to look toward
the middle of the loop the entire time
and then as you go toward the top here
the seats are going to stay horizontal
and after that they're going to be
rotated toward the next
section that actually looks quite good
that's more or less what we're looking
for uh now interestingly they're going
to start uh rotating back here and
that's something I don't want to do I
want to set it to 210 for this entire
section did I put that to positive 210
that's something to keep in mind uh yeah
that's positive 210 so I want to set
that over here as well because I kind of
want to keep people on their backs sort
of facing upwards let's take one more
look at it make sure that we're on the
right track it's going to rotate over
here going to go upside down and we're
going to be lying for this entire
section perfect that is just what we're
looking for now we're going to do
something interesting here uh because at
the end of the zero g ra here we want to
start moving down again I can actually
make this a little bit steeper I just
realized it's it's not that deep here
and for the section that we have after
the Z where we're going to go straight
again I'm going to move the seats uh
360° so I want to have the seats doing a
vertical 360 while the train cars
themselves are doing a sort of 360 roll
over during the Zer g roll I'm not sure
if that makes any sense but basically it
means you're going to rotate in two
different dimensions and this is also
kind of why I guess this coaster is
called a fourth dimension because even
though it doesn't technically break the
fourth dimension iion uh you do kind of
move in four dimensions um but yeah I'm
going to rotate the seats 360 because I
want to do a 360 during this thing and
because we were at 210° before we went
into it I want to be at Min
-50° as we leave it and that should
leave us in the same position and that
should leave the cars doing a full 360
as they go through the zero g now just
as a quick test I want to smooth out
this stuff make make sure that it's all
good and make sure that the zjo itself
is smooth as well and we're going to do
a quick test again to see how it's
running so the cars are coming here
they're doing an interesting 360 on this
section already lying down for a little
bit and then while they are on the Zer g
roll right here I'm not sure if you can
really tell um but you can see them
actually rotating as you're on the Zer
as well and then as you come out of it
you're in the same line position that
you were when you enter the zjo
and that's perfect and just about what
we're looking for now next I want to
have a bit of a turnaround element
because these coasters usually have an
Outback Outback kind of layout to them
which means that first we're going to
get out there go away from the station
then we're going to turn back here and
we're going to turn again get out there
again and then finally return to the
station so this is basically the point
where these rides would often find some
way to turn around and this is usually
just a simple curve it isn't really uh
that exciting of an element it's really
sort of a bit of a downtime during the
ride so I'm not going to do too much
special stuff over here just a simple
curve uh but what I do want to make sure
that is that I want to make this a very
long winding curve because I want to
make the layout as compact as possible
and I really want to stay close to the
track which I have so far um and what I
also want to do is I want to bank the
track just enough so that we get some
supports on the sides as you'll notice
if you have a straight piece of track
you're going to have supports uh like
these uh whereas if I bank it just a
little bit more we should hopefully end
up with some supports uh that I'm
actually looking for there we go we can
end up with the supports on the side now
I wouldn't say you necessarily have to
bank the track this much but I
personally just like doing that uh
because it means you get some slightly
better
supports guess that's also just kind of
whatever you prefer in this case in any
case uh we're moving back toward the
other side now uh I do want to make sure
that I sort of keep the track banked a
little bit here and only start unbanking
once we actually get to a very straight
section uh so something like that should
work let's see not come too close to the
ground there we go and um now I want to
do something interesting over here
actually in real life uh what most of
them do at this point is just have a
simple straight light to fly element
which is similar to the zjo I'll show it
off uh in the last section of this
layout um but I want to do something
special here because I do want to add a
little bit of creativity to this coaster
reason being is that there are only
three of these in real life so uh there
is sort of a template to how you should
be building these things but I don't
think you should listen to that too
closely because obviously this is one of
the most interesting coaster types ever
and there's a lot of fun stuff that you
can mess around with when it comes to
these coasters there's definitely a lot
of creativity that you can uh get to in
the layouts and the rotations of the
seats uh that makes it worth not
listening to the rules every now and
then and in that just break them and
there's this really interesting uh sort
of elements to these kinds of coasters
which used to be a bit of a thing in the
roller coaster 3 community on Flying
Dutchman coasters it's basically an over
banked curve but halfway through the
over banked curve you're going to go
into the other direction I know that
makes no sense anyway uh so I'll just
show off what I mean uh basically we
want to start going up and we want to
start going into a curve and now we're
going to very slowly increase the
banking on this curve here kind of like
we're making a cork screw actually I
would say this is very similar to a cork
screw uh but instead of um you know
being completely upside down on the top
we're being 90° on the top here so
basically at this point we have half an
over banked curve because we've got the
curve here and we're banked over here
and now you would normally say okay
we're going to go back and we're going
to curve into this direction again well
that's not what we're going to do here
we're actually going to curve around to
the other side to be very honest I have
no idea how well this would work in real
life in terms of forces but these things
don't do this element in real life but I
think it's a very interesting uh Light
toly Element and it's definitely in the
light toly elements that I think you can
do some very creative stuff with these
coasters and uh not sure why my auto
tunnel is on again but anyway I want to
end the over banked curve over here the
shaping might be a little bit awkward so
that's definitely uh a small concern
here but it's it's not too big of an
issue as soon as we get into these
strike sections make sure to smooth them
out the more you hit the smooth button
the more it's actually going to become a
very smooth winning overbank curve let's
see that and finally the middle
section and um I know that looks very
strange it is definitely a very weird
element and it's very heavily inspired
by what Flying Dutchman coas do uh which
aren't in the game that might be
interesting to talk about anyway um but
it's an interesting light to fly element
and those light to fly elements are
basically just one element where it goes
from upside down to uh straight up track
or the other way around and there are
many different ways in which you can
build these things and I think this is
really where your own creativity can
shine through most because any part of a
track can be turned into a light toly
element and I think there's a lot of
creativity that you can have with that
um now to make the coaster a little bit
more compax I do think I want to
increase the curve on this thing a
little bit
and stay a bit more close to what we've
had so
far there we go and at this point I
think we want to start going up again
because at this point is usually where
these coasters usually go into their
second Raven turn now what's interesting
is that the second Raven turn is often a
little bit different from the first one
it's still the same shape it is still a
raven turn um but there's a bit of a
Twist to it in that it actually starts
off on the top instead of going from the
bottom up and you start off um with
having the top being the uh right side
up part instead of The Upside Down Parts
as it is over here uh so it's a bit of a
slightly different element and I think
that makes it quite interesting I do
want to start curving this around though
because I'm going to try and squeeze in
the section after the Raven turn over
the track here to make my coaster as
compact as possible so we'll see if I
can actually make that actually think in
order to put P that off I might have to
make this slope a little bit more
gentle there we go let's just make that
a rather gentle slope and after that go
into the Raven turn not too sure how the
speed is over here either as that's
something that I'll have to keep in mind
as well and um we're basically going to
do the same as we did for the Raven turn
on the other side let's see I think
that's going to be a little bit too
slow yeah that can be a little bit
faster let's make this bit shorter and
we should be good to go there we go that
is looking pretty good and I want to
have a very slight curve over here
because I want to start moving over the
track here and we're basically going to
go down and form a half Loop over here I
always want to make sure to make these
half Loops out of very small track
Pieces Just so you have a little bit
more control over the loop uh because
even though this is a half Loop we still
want to make sure that we got that
signature teardrop shape into the loop
here and we want to make sure that the
top part is actually a little bit more
compact uh of a curve than the bottom
part because in the bottom we're
definitely going to be quite a bit
faster than at the top and we want to
make sure that we're not going through
this too
quickly that's going to come very close
to the ground I'll see about how well
that's going to work out but it looks
like after a bit of smoothing that's
going to form a pretty good element so
let's
see uh that should be it for some
general smoothing I want to smooth out
this section A little bit more don't
want to have any Hills where it has a
very straight section and finally
especially those transitions between the
elements are very important so let's
grab all of that this looks like it
could use a little bit more smoothing
and finally the bottom of the elements
definitely be smooth out a bit as well
and I think we can go into the next
section now the next section is going to
be a very standard light to fly element
I figured I'm going to have to put one
of these in the layouts anyway way
because this is you know this is a
fourth dimension coaster there's no way
you can build one of these without the
classical standard light to fly so we're
just going to get into that it's very
simple it's like the Zer g roll but
instead of uh turning the track 180°
we're going to just turn the track uh
90° uh or instead of turning the track
360° we're going to turn the track 180°
sorry so at this point all we really
want to do is make sure that we have a
small hill going on here and we're
gradually going to a track that is
completely straight and upward actually
getting some very good supports here I'm
really happy with that sometimes it can
be very tricky to get the supports right
with these kinds of coasters so it might
take a little bit of puzzling uh to make
sure that you're not removing any
supports that might be necessary because
these coasters do have a very large hit
box and it's very important to be aware
of the fact that these uh coasters do
have their carriages on the side of the
track so you want to make sure that
you're not removing too many of your own
supports now let's smooth this out for a
little bit and before I actually finish
the coaster I want to do one last thing
I want to start at the end and make sure
we have a small slope going on here and
I also want to put some block brakes
over here because this is where we're
going to have to stall the second train
once we have it and I want to have some
friction brakes to slow down the coaster
and at this point I think we're pretty
much good to go and make the connection
uh let's see where we have to go with
this looks like that's not going to be
too great of a connection see if I can
have a very slight curve to
this yeah that'll be more or less okay I
can actually unbank this quite a bit
doesn't need to have all of that banking
I want to quickly mention that I added
one extra car to the train since it was
a little bit too slow for my liking
especially at the end of the track and
while these coasters definitely do lose
a lot of speed and that's something to
keep in mind
um just adding that one extra car should
hopefully make it a little bit faster
think I could also roll over that Hill a
little bit faster like the difference
between the height of this hill and the
height of the lift Hill end uh could
definitely be a bit bigger but that
aside I'm actually quite happy with the
overall layout and the speed of it I
don't want stuff to go too quickly but
obviously we're not done yet there's
actually still some work to be done so
let's head into the editor and before I
do anything else I want to quickly add a
catwalk alongside The Brak run
uh just because we definitely want to
have that and also we want to go into
the rotation of the seats and this is
where stuff is going to get complicated
again uh though not quite yet uh what I
want to do with the over banked curve
and this is a little bit of an
interesting kind of small thing is I
want to keep that same uh minus
150 uh Dee rotation angle more or less
for the entire curve as well uh but
there's one one extra thing that I do
want to add over here here I want to
slightly change the rotation of the
seats as we're going into the overbank
curve I'm not sure uh to what extent
this is really true on most of them um
but you can mess with the seats a little
bit on the overbank curve like kind of
turn them toward the track and that's
something that I do want to mess with
here uh so I'm going to grab one of the
beginning Parts just turn on the
rotation again here and um actually I'm
going to try to keep it a bit more
smooth I'm going to turn on the rotation
here and I'm going to go to a section in
the middle of it and turn on the
rotation over here as well except turn
it to 12 so that we're actually moving
toward the track itself a little bit
more and I'm going to do the same thing
on the other sign of the overbank curve
and turn it to 120 normally you don't
really see them doing anything super
weird alongside these overbank curves so
no double back flips or front flips or
anything like that but still a bit of
spinning with the cars I guess you still
want to do something with it and next I
also want to do some sort of spinning on
this element so just before we head into
the elements I want to hold the same
seed angle just to make sure that we're
not going to get some awkward rotations
before we get into the element and what
I want to do with the element itself um
is I want to get to a 360 on the other
side okay so I'm testing the ride and
what I've added is a quick section where
it goes to so 360° on this side and
you'll notice that the seats are
flipping as it goes over this weird over
banked curve element so they'll be doing
a flip while also the seats of the train
themselves are sort of doing a 180 flip
which is just going to make stuff a bit
more interesting around this side so now
we're getting into the second Raven turn
and I again kind of want to do a flip
before we go into the Raven turn and
then look toward the middle of the turn
as we're doing the turn itself uh so I'm
going to go to this section and set this
to about- 60 at least while I was
testing my layout that turned out to be
quite good and I'll set this to about
minus 150 now also as we're going into
this last Light to fly I want to make
sure that the uh seats are revolving
again as well and going back into the
original station uh sort of seat
positioning so I'm going to turn this to
150 before we get into the elements and
then at the end of the elements I'm
going to turn it down to about 160 which
should provide some pretty good seating
and I'm going to do the same for this
section on the brake run here and then
when we're on the brake run we can
transition to the seating element which
we should have at the very end of the
coaster which is all the way back at
zero which is automatically doing that's
pretty good actually and that is more or
less the layout I'll give it one more
test to show you how everything is
working and of course a POV and talk to
you a bit more about what is going on so
let's look at the coaster one last time
so first off as we're on the LIF Hill
we're rotating toward our backs looking
up toward the sky and then suddenly we
start going backward and as a personal
idea I would definitely say that this
second Hill can be a bit lower it's
creeping over it pretty slowly but the
idea is there we're turning on our backs
behind uh all of this area looking
toward the middle of the loop here doing
a pretty cool flip as we get into the
end of the loop and lying again
underneath the track doing a 360 Flip as
the track itself is also twisting
360° then we go into the overbank curve
where the seats are rotating a little
bit but not too much into the Crazy
Light to fly elements where the seats
are moving in all kinds of weird ways
into the final Raven turn where they're
going to rotate again and at the end of
this sort of be looking
horizontally and finally a final lighter
fly element at the end of which um they
should actually be looking toward a
different place hold up there we go my
bad that should have been just a regular
60 as we had at the beginning of the
ride uh might actually want to turn that
down to maybe about 45° again I'm not
too sure about the ways that these seats
are rotated since it's hard to really
measure it off of videos or probably off
of being there in the first place but
the general idea is that we're returning
back to the original position as we get
into the break run there now finally of
course I want to do a quick POV so let's
get into the ride let's skip the LIF
Hill for a second since that's you know
the the standard Fair of doing a lift
Hill basically the way it's going to
look as you're in the lift Hill is
you're just going to be looking at the
sky maybe if you're at your feet I guess
if that if that's uh what you like doing
while you're on the lift Hill and
finally we're going to head into the
drop over here look down toward our doom
and uh rotate back toward our back X and
sort of look into the middle of the loop
that's always something that I really
like seeing I'm going to flip again
listen to some weird techno music and um
the absolutely crazy ridiculous zerog g
roll where everything is twisting in
360° looking a bit toward the over
banked curve over here and finally
rotating back again here doing the crazy
element where it moves to the other side
I'm actually quite a fan of that one and
flipping again as we go into the final
Raven turn
and finally a light to fly elements and
that should finish off the ride pretty
nicely yeah I think I could actually
move that final light to fly to about 45
maybe 30° something like that again a
lot of this also comes down to whatever
you prefer and what your taste really is
and a lot of trial and error to make
sure that the position of the seats are
right but this is a general idea this is
really what the footprint of many of
these RS look like quite compact very
lengthy and narrow
and um they do have very impressive
skylines with those signature first
drops with the small pre- drops uh all
of those Raven turns around here and
those large uh overbank curves around
the side so yeah this is basically a
fourth dimension type of coaster
definitely don't take this as a
blueprint to make exact copies of this
this is very much like the standard uh
four-dimensional Coes out there um I
would just say sort of follow the same
temp plates but it can be a lot of fun
to try and be as creative as you can
with some of these elements because this
is you know this is one of the most
difficult coers but this is at the same
time one of the most creative coasters
there is so much you can do with those
Light toly Elements and with the
inversions uh in combination with the
rotating seats so definitely this is a
hard coaster to get used to and it's a
very hard coaster to actually Master uh
but once you've actually you know got
the basics done and and you can handle
it it's a lot of fun to try and mess
around with this coaster and come up
with your own layouts so that's
basically all I have to say for this
episode this was also incidentally to
sort of end this video again with some
random coaster stuff uh this was also
incidentally my last Arrow video of the
U Planet coaster College Series my
intention at this point was to go
through all of the arrow and the SNS
coasters because SNS has uh pretty much
bought all the rights to the old Arrow
rides um so yeah this is pretty much my
last of the Arrow versus SNS things and
it's also the one that I was uh afraid
of the most myself since it's quite a
difficult one but what's interesting
about this is that this is originally an
arrow ride Arrow was the company that
developed X which was the first uh
fourth dimension coaster and it was also
the right that eventually made the
company bankrupt and at some point asns
bought the arrow right and uh they
refurbed X made it into X2 which
nowadays is known as one of the best
coas in the world generally seen and
they've also made two other uh rides of
this type Dino Konda in China and aanika
in Japan which are very similar to X
except a bit larger and with some
slightly different elements but they
look very similar and I think uh without
any prior knowledge of what exactly the
differences between these coers are you
might as well mistake them as complete
copies
so yeah this is this is both an arrow
and an SNS ride at the same time and
it's one of the most interesting rides
out there actually something that I
haven't talked about uh is that the way
that these cars are rotating is not with
any computer technology or anything
that's remotely controlled but actually
with a second rails uh on the track
you've got the rails on the side here uh
which there are some Wheels running on
those rails on the sides and they are
controlling these mechanisms which which
you see over here which is spinning the
seats on the sides now in Planet coaster
itself and I guess I really can't hate
on Frontier for this because it would
have been way too difficult and uh time
and money consuming to actually get into
that but in Planet coaster itself uh
there isn't really anything going on
with those rails on the sides they're
really just there for realism uh but in
real life you'll actually be able to
tell uh that these rails on the sides
are moving up and down in relation to
the actual rails that the coaster is
running on uh so you can actually tell
by the way that the rails looks what
kind of rotation the car is going to do
at that point which is super interesting
this is in terms of engineering Feats
this is one of the most fascinating
roller coasters out there but yeah
that's that's basically my my coaster
nerd for today I hope you guys enjoyed
this video I am super glad to have it
done since this was really the most
difficult Planet coaster College to do
so far but of course as always uh don't
be afraid to leave your feedback or
questions if you have them um or any
improvements that I should be making and
I'll gladly consider it so yeah again
thank you guys for watching I hope you
learn something and I'll see you guys in
the next video